If you want to hear three theories about the
setup for a sequel, then stick around to the
end of this video.
Michael Myers, Jason, Freddy, Pennywise, Leatherface
and many others have just welcomed a new member
to their exclusive club of horror icon remakes
and that member is Chucky.
Today on Things You Missed I’ll be covering
everything you might have missed in the 2019
Child’s Play.
The new film is very different from the original,
but it’s absolutely loaded with nods and
parallels to the original Child’s Play series,
many of which I think you’ll be surprised
to learn.
The movie begins with this introduction video
to this company Kaslan, who are very similar
to Play Pals Toys from the original series,
in that they produce the doll and all sorts
of accessories.
In fact, we see the inside of the factory
where the Buddi dolls are produced and it’s
very similar visually to the factory that
Chucky chases Kyle and Andy through in Child's
Play 2.
It is here that we discover the origin of
Chucky’s evil.
This time it’s not a serial killer transferring
his evil soul into the body, but rather, a
factory worker programming his evil intentions
into the source code of this toy.
The worker later throws himself off the building
and lands on a car for the first death of
the movie.
Aunt Maggie lands on a car for the first death
in the original Child’s Play.
When Andy’s mom comes home from work, the
IT guy is installing cameras in the halls
made by Kaslan, so it seems like they control
almost all technology in this world, but I’ll
come back to that later in this video.
In both this and the original, Andy’s Mom
gets the doll second hand, in the original
it’s a street peddler and now it’s a returned
item to the store she works at.
The name of the doll has been changed from
Good Guys to Buddi, but don’t worry, this
isn’t a betrayal of the original, it’s
actually a reference to the real world doll
that the original is based on: the My Buddy
doll.
Legend says that 80s kids still have the jingle
stuck in their heads and so will you after
I roll it!
“My Buddy.
My Buddy!
Wherever I goes, he goes...”
The name change also just works well with
modern tech’s strange gravitation towards
lower case i’s.
I guess it’s supposed to stand for internet,
but after being overused in every tech product,
I think we can agree that it stands for insufferable.
Andy’s Mom tells him to go make friends
with some kids standing outside, but he says
he doesn’t want to, they could be serial
killers, a little nod to the fact that in
the original, the Good Guy doll is possessed
by a serial killer.
Also, there’s a possible connection in that
Andy likes to draw these strange Buddy Cop
pairings in his notebook -- could be a reference
to the two cops who help take down Chucky
in the 1988 film.
Errr… at least one of them helps.
In this version, the kids are given the opportunity
to give a custom name to their toy.
Andy names his Han Solo.
Big missed opportunity to not go with Luke
Skywalker instead, seeing as how Chucky is
voiced by the man who plays Luke Skywalker.
There’s also a song known as The Buddi song
that goes: “You are my Buddi, until the
end.”
The original Chucky doesn’t sing, but he
does have a phrase that goes: “we’re friends
to the end.”
"Hi, I'm Oscar and I'm your friend to the
end!"
OK -- so the next part is what I find the
most interesting, because this remake has
its own plot that isn’t similar to the original
but the overarching idea is the same, but
in a modern setting.
What I’m talking about is the fact that
Chucky’s voodoo possession of the doll in
the 1988 movie causes him to slowly become
human, but in the 2019 remake, he’s just
an AI with safety restrictions removed, but
he learns how to behave by watching and imitating
the humans.
So in a sense, he’s slowly becoming human
throughout the movie, because he’s learning
to behave like a human.
Unfortunately, the humans he’s taking his
cues from are irresponsible pre-teens who
teach him to do bad stuff for laughs, so Chucky
begins to see this as acceptable behaviour.
They also show him The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
2, which causes Chucky to remove one of his
victims’ faces, and is probably influenced
by other horror movies, judging from the posters
on the kid’s wall like Killer Klowns from
Outer Space and Poltergeist III, both of which
came out in 1988, the same year as the original
Child’s Play.
One aspect of the new story is that Andy is
given Chucky as an early birthday present
because his Mom knows the move has been hard
on him.
There’s also a point later where he gives
a gift to the neighbor, Mrs. Norris and tells
her they can open gifts together on his birthday.
So there’s a looser connection here to Andy
from the original, who receives the Good Guy
doll as a last minute birthday gift.
Now this next one, I don’t know if it would
count as a Thing You Missed -- maybe more
of a disturbing thing that I thought about
after the fact…
I’m just not gonna start a whole web-series
called Disturbing Things I Thought About After
The Fact… but Chucky starts by killing Andy’s
cat, and that night Chucky stands in his room
and plays back cat noises.
These were probably the sounds of the cat’s
final moments, a pretty messed up soundtrack
to fall asleep to.
I think I’ll stick with lofi chillhop beats
to study/relax/sleep for my bedtime music
choices.
Chucky’s next victim is Karen’s boyfriend
Shane, because for some reason all guys who
date a single mother in movies turn out to
be evil -- like seriously -- try to name one
exception to this rule.
He’s taking down Christmas lights when Chucky
finds him, which tells us that this movie
still takes place in January like the original
despite the fact that it seems to be in a
warm-weather climate as opposed to Chicago.
Taking down the lights was a neat way to show
this without drawing too much attention to
an otherwise unnecessary detail.
Chucky attacks him in a very similar way to
how Aunt Maggie is attacked with Chucky rushing
around in the dark before knocking his victim
down from a high up place.
He tears Shane’s face off and his hair lands
on a garden gnome, which instantly made me
think of this Keemstar video from 2016 where
he wears an emo wig and pretends to be LeafyIsHere.
“I want to kill myself.”
"Also in the news."
When Andy and his friends realize that Chucky
has gone too far, they take steps to deactivate
it and they do so by removing, what I’m
assuming is supposed to be the battery, which
is located in the center of his chest, just
like the heart that they have to shoot to
kill Chucky in the original.
"Kill them all!"
"The heart!
Shoot him in the heart!"
After doing this, they toss him down the garbage
shoot, thinking that will be it.
But like Child’s Play 1, 2, and 3, Chucky
always finds a way to come back whenever you
think that he’s done for.
And when he does, he kills the pervy IT guy
that put him back together.
I guess in addition to watching Texas Chainsaw
movies with Chucky, they must have also been
watching some Saw.
Chucky gets back into Andy’s life by mailing
himself to one of the other kids in Andy’s
building, which brings up the exact same question
I had in my video on Child’s Play 3: how
do you wrap a package if YOU’RE INSIDE OF
IIIIIITTTTT--
But this brings us to another interesting
parallel to the original, which is that Andy
is the only one to realize that this is the
same Chucky as the one he had, and as a result,
everybody thinks Andy is crazy.
The old Andy was put in the hospital, but
this one just goes all Anthony Rizzo on the
TV.
Could have just unplugged it.
All you had to do.
There’s also a scene where Mrs. Norris goes
in a Kaslan car, which like Kaslan’s version
of Uber, and Chucky takes control of it and
crashes it.
Remember, Mrs. Norris is the mother of Detective
Mike Norris, and in the original, Detective
Norris also gets his car crashed as a result
of Chucky, and the part that follows where
Chucky attacks from 360° around the car is
very similar in both movies.
The climax takes place in the store that Andy’s
Mom works at where they’re having the launch
of the brand new Buddi 2, which includes different
forms such as The Buddi Bear, an obvious Five
Nights at Freddy Reference and the Leprechaun
outfit…
I guess… possibly a Leprechaun reference…
But the idea of there being multiple Buddi
dolls being taken over by Chucky itself is
a reference to the previous movie in the franchise,
Cult of Chucky, where Charles Lee Ray manages
to get his soul into multiple bodies.
I’ve heard this is an idea they wanted to
use for a long time, but didn’t, but if
you think about it, it actually makes sense
here since Chucky is stated to have the ability
to control all Kaslan products.
Also, the RC police car that shouts out the
Robocop line could also be a nod towards Child’s
Play 3 -- where one of the toys that Chucky
uses to attack Play Pals CEO Mr. Sullivan
is this toy car.
Those of you who watched my video on the original
Child’s Play…
I wonder how many times I said the word original
during this video….?
But those who saw it may remember my idea
to make a whole movie off the creepy mascot
from the Good Guy unveiling commercial.
Well, in the new one, they use a creepy mascot
to during the unveiling of the actual product
in stores -- and while it wasn’t a whole
movie, I was glad to see the mascot being
used for something.
It’s no secret that one of the most beloved
scenes in the Child’s Play franchise is
the final factory scene from Child’s Play
2, so to replicate some of that magic, the
reboot throws Andy into a final confrontation
with Chucky in the warehouse at the back of
the store, something that is alluded to earlier
on when Andy’s Mom blackmails her co-worker
Wes, by threatening to tell his wife what
went on between him and a woman named Susan
in the warehouse.
Chucky kidnaps Andy’s Mom and tries to hang
her, which is how he killed the factory supervisor
in Child’s Play 2, but Andy makes it just
in time to save her.
But as we know, and have established many
times, Chucky always finds a way to come back,
and this time it’s Detective Norris with
the heroic one-liner where he says, “this
is the end.”
Very similar to OG Andy’s line.
“This is
the end, friend.”
Except this time, it really is the end.
Well… maybe not.
The company Kaslan issues a statement where
they take no responsibility for the incident,
which parallels their PR response to their
stockholders in Child’s Play 2, and an evil
Buddi doll ends up on store shelves once more.
So the question about this ending is how did
Chucky survive?
We saw him get shot in the chest and his head
was pulled off.
There are a few possibilities.
If they are trying to setup a sequel along
the lines of Child’s Play 2, it’s possible
that the company reconstructed Chucky to appease
their stockholders.
But I already covered why that’s a terrible
idea in my video on the second one, so another
possibility is that this simply wasn’t the
only one -- the disgruntled Vietnamese worker
could have made several rogue dolls for all
we know.
But my favorite theory is that because this
iteration of Chucky is connected to the cloud
and can interact with other Buddi dolls, it
could have sent it’s AI and everything that
it learned to other dolls, meaning Andy or
some unlucky kid could be up against a whole
army of Chuckys in the sequel.
Let me know which theory you would get behind
in the comments.
I’ve gotten a lot of requests to cover Bride
of Chucky, Seed, Curse and Cult here on Things
You Missed, so with a sequel probably going
to happen now I’ll definitely have to do
those in the future.
So make sure you are subscribed to CZsWorld,
I post new horrors every week, just ring the
deathbell for notifications and I’ll see
you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.